[Music]
the circle pit is part of every heaven
shall burn gig and their appearance at
this year's Wacken the world's largest
metal festival was no exception
[Music]
we popped by the artists village to meet
frontman Markus and guitarist Mike it's
the band's sixth outing at buck an
open-air but your band makes it here the
whole world takes note we just toured
South America and people were always
asking us about vodka what's it like
playing there are we glad to be back
this year it was a big deal and that's
so important for a bands international
image invade bite beastie heaven shall
burn a somewhat cynical name maybe but
there's nothing satanical about these
guys they're more into saving the earth
the video for khorium was shot in
Argentina and Chile where they've toured
frequently having grown up in communist
East Germany this was a dream come true
[Music]
this debate was the few bits I travel
the world get paid meet a bunch of cool
people in most countries all it costs is
a phone call lend on the vehicles and we
have a buddy we can visit and a place to
crash we'll open the fog as it built a
large network of friends and that's a
huge gift me guy make our courses
[Music]
this metalcore group doesn't make
feel-good music the video for the song
combat shows shocking images of child
soldiers caught up in the horrors of war
[Music]
HSB doesn't only criticize violence and
racism in their music
they pay the price yet this Facebook
posting must be a millennial - last time
we post a Facebook message against Nazis
it costs us a few hundred fans each
clear statement we make on TV costs us
CD sales there are people who love our
music but whose political views are
totally different but that's an
important part of who we are we can do
without those kinds of fans in 2015 they
won some new fans when they became
sponsors at the Soccer Club Cartagena
and a teams jerseys are now in worldwide
demand in 2017 the band also persuaded
the buckin foundation for young metal
bands to join them all for a good cause
clubs are making a difference Carl Zeiss
Jena is supporting an initiative for
parents whose children have cancer and
now the vaccum foundation can also tell
that a lot of young people in the
stadium are excited to find
opportunities to get involved and that's
so important
inspiring people something heaven shall
burn have been doing for 20 years and
they're not done yet we don't need to
explain ourselves or prove anything
we're not like some of the younger bands
who say oh they're bigger and they've
got more effects we don't care about any
of that we look forward to our shows and
our fans as we've been doing for years
one can use them when the Savior
a metal band with a message heaven shall
burn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]